alors donc une candidat déclenché au
talkie walkie de secours pour alerter la
production d'un problème c'était dans la
nuit de mardi à mercredi au quatrième
jour de tournage
elles auraient été victimes d'agressions
sexuelles de la part d'un autre candidat
la production décide alors d'isoler les
deux candidats séparément pour éclaircir
la situation
constat donc c'est parole contre parole
la réunion il ya une réunion production
jolie mercredi pour décider de la suite
ou non de l'aventuré et la production a
décidé où il apprit à la gelée a pris
jeudi matin jeudi de stopper le tournage
de koh lanta est de faire revenir tous
les candidats ici si vous avez des
questions à l'isi n'hésitez pas il ya
des questions également sur twitter que
ce qui moi je suis allé parce que dans
ces émissions mais il ya des choses que
m d'espère des candidats qui sont là en
réserve c'est un problème sur de santé
et c'est pourquoi il n'ya pas avoir
exfiltrer les deux candidats et les
dames a remporté par de ce père et
continuer l'aventuré alors je vais vous
dire pourquoi on ne pouvait pas garder
tous les candidats sur l'île les
candidats de koh lanta parce que il y a
la jeune fille allait porter plainte
et forcément tous les candidats doivent
être entendus forcément on devait faire
rapatrier tous les candidats en france
pour que la plainte soit déposée
puisqu'elle n'avait pas porté plainte
aux îles fidji elle est laval a porté
plainte la roque sénat et donc les
candidats fait écho ni la feuille de
route où les candidats doivent être
entendus donc forcément pouvais pas les
laisser sur l'île donc ils sont tous
sans rentrer après vous me demandez
voilà que s'est il passé vraiment c'est
la première question est qui a été posée
je vous dis hein la jeune fille a priori
voilà la version qui auraient été donnés
c'est que la jeune fille donc s'élever
pendant la nuit pour aller faire pipi
voilà donc voilà pour dans koh lanta
donc elle est partie sur l'île
elle a été donc faire ses besoins elle
est revenue à sa place est à sa place
quelqu'un d'autre s'ils étaient mis donc
elle a changé de place elle est venue
s'allonger à côté d'un titre d'un des
garçons de koh lanta donc le garçon a
cru que elle venait s'allonger à côté de
lui parce que voilà elle était peut-être
intéressé par lui
donc il a tenté voilà à priori voilà
quelque chose avec elle elle n'a pas
voulu et forcément elle a alerté tout de
suite la production et grâce aux taux
qui motive cette vision un talkie walkie
voilà qui de secours pour alerter s'il
ya une urgence voilà donc c'est ce qui
se serait passé
après on sait pas ce qui s'est passé
vraiment rtement va le savoir dans les
dents les proches
un jour c'est vraiment parole contre
parole voilà je voulais il a vu ce matin
il est sortie exacte car la nuit ni
complètement les faits il exactement
c'est eddy un édit s'appelle eddy ils
aient été menées directement en garde à
vue à sa sortie de l'avion
quatre heures plus tard il est relâché
donc sa garde à vue n'a pas duré
longtemps
un joli l'avocat du candidat déclare
aucun motif ne permettait de maintenir
mon client en garde à vue sa version des
faits parfaitement conforme avec celle
des cinq autres personnes qui étaient
dans la dans la hutte avec la plaignante
versez la version de la plaignante donc
sur l enquête a été ouverte
exactement l'enquêté est ouverte
l'enquêté n'est pas terminée puisque le
parquet de nancy va désormais se charger
de la sphère oui j'ai une question pour
vous on a parlé d'abord d'interruption
du chômage puis un peu après
d'annulation est ce qu a eu la tentation
à un moment de reprendre le tournage
bientôt venir mais alors je vais vous
dire très vite la production a décidé
d'annuler complètement la saison on
pouvait pas et la production ne pouvait
pas donc garder koh lanta à l'antenne
avec ces présomptions et qui sont des
faits très graves dont vous pouvez pas
garder l'aventuré koh lanta là comme ça
même exfiltrer les deux candidats
vraiment pour l'ambiance était compliqué
donc est vraiment une foule dit la
production a décidé d'elle-même
adventure line productions de stopper le
tournage voilà donc il y aura pas de
saison de koh lanta sur tf1 en septembre
oui au niveau financier comment ça se
passe parce que c'est l'un des
programmes les plus porteurs pente et
enfin huit cent mille euros c'est le
coût d'un programme de l'est aujourd'hui
à peu près par émission pas par émission
c'est je viens même à présent très ce
qu'elle ressent que ça voilà voilà
on est allé j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont
été très vite sans avoir les résultats
c'est que ça qui a pris alors je vous
dirai en face que ça coûte tf1
engrangent environ tous les deux
millions d'euros de recettes nettes par
émission est soit 30 millions d'euros
par saison ce qui est énorme
bien sûr pour tf1 et vous l'avez compris
donc le manque à gagner va être
conséquent selon ce que je sais voilà je
vous dis les contrats d'assurance
souscrits par la production mine de rien
on prévoit tout un sauf ça donc
forcément la production a priori
n'imaginais pas donc se retrouver dans
cette situation je vous dis et la
production se retrouver pour la
production pourrait se retrouver seul à
supporter financièrement bien sûr
l'arrêt brutal de cette édition sera pas
juste non rapatriement bien sûr de ses
équipes à paris tout ça c'est supporté
par la production
donc voilà je vous dis
sakho manque à gagner willems à 8
millions d'euros environ oui au départ
comme il ya deux saisons c'est 20 30
millions donc dans l'année oui mais non
merci
oui oui non comment ça se passe
maintenant chez alp dans le sens où il
ya déjà eu des précédents
ça c'est la question que tout le monde
se pose des précédents évidemment pas au
niveau sexuel des petits incidents des
arts et des missions au moins certain
qu'il ya eu des grosses lan / sur la
boîte de production alors dans la boîte
de production vrai giuly c'est que koh
lanta on espère que ça va revenir à
l'antenne je vous le dis parce que koh
lanta ça reste quand même un peu un
programme qui cartonne
tf1 a besoin de koh lanta c'est un
programme moi je pense personnellement
j'espère que cette histoire n'est pas
très grave en tout cas je trouve
après je dis pas parce qu'il est pas ça
parce que voilà je suis dans le même
groupe et que c'est important je trouve
que la production a pris la bonne
décision en arrêtons la saison c'est un
gros manque à gagner mais je trouve et
j'espère que ce ne sera pas grave je
pense que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
koh lanta parce que tf1 tirer trop sur
la corde de koh lanta on a rêvé dans
tous les sens moi moi à voir revoir
collante en septembre franchement ça me
gave et giuly je pense que les s'est un
peu reposé koh lanta ça va faire du bien
à tout le monde et ça va faire surtout
du bien aux programmes
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
je pense que ce serait une bonne
nouvelle oui et déjà le casting de la
saison de printemps koh lanta qui est
déjà en cours de la vingtième saison
alexia m'a pas menti et bien sûr au
réveil mais là on parle on parle
vraiment de du sucré l'acide de 2,7 de
cette affaire est-ce que je dise quelque
chose mais est ce qu'il ya une remise en
cause de dlp de sur eux mêmes à la
réduction de la production en se disant
est-ce qu'on a peut-être fait une erreur
de casting est ce que de se replonger
dans les castings qu'ils ont fait alors
ça je peux pas répondre mais où est ce
que vous trouvez vous que le casting de
koh lanta on outils en ce moment voilà
je vous le dis c'est vrai que vous dites
que et on cherche des noms je ne t'ai
pas téléralité mon cher des personnages
personnage haut en couleur alors
qu'avant on cherchait plus des
aventuriers c'est vrai que les deux
marches et c'est vrai que là en ce
moment il faut avouer c'est aussi une
entreprise commerciale
cf1 et on ménagères que l'on t'a marche
très très fort parce qu'il ya aussi ces
gros personnage s vous vous trouvez que
c'est une erreur oui alors très
franchement moi je ne me reconnais plus
dans le casting à calais je discute
beaucoup avec des anciens candidats il
ne s'y reconnaissent plus
il trouve qui a plu d'aventuriers assez
des personnages qui sont là pour faire
le buzz qui sont fortes la pour des
stratégies hyper agressive qui vont trop
loin
donc je pense que dans le casting
peut-être qu'en a tiré trop loin sur ces
personnages hors normes à tous regardent
yacine restions imaginer que finalement
cette histoire est une c'est faux c'est
intégralement faux moi j'ai des infos
lors c'est sûrement des on dit on m'a
dit oui mais elle a déclenché tôt qui
parce qu'il était en difficulté pour le
premier conseil c'est ce que j'ai vu
comment comme info imaginez que tout ça
soit faux archi faux
donc ça veut dire que à cause de ça il
ya quand même des dommages collatéraux
et des cadors qui vont pas mort qui ont
perdu un emploi il ya une boîte de
production qui va assumer des coûts
quand même énorme considérable quid
qu'est ce qui se passe si cette histoire
est fausse compassion va se retourner
vers la seine-saint-denis d'accord ah
bah oui non vers la jeune fille qui à
pied qui voit là où la jeune fille ou
voilà leur confiance à la justice
on espère que ce qu'on va voir la
lumière sur cette affaire je vous dis
mais forcément que ce soit la production
où que ce soit tf1
ça peut aller très très loin d'accord
non mais de toute façon il ya un premier
casting parce que si si bien son a
commis cette chose horrible
l'erreur de casting au niveau du
comportement si la jeune fille a menti
une erreur de casting de toute façon il
ya un déficit à dessus et c'est vrai
qu'on la dit ici de plus en plus les
missions moi ce que j'aime à peu près
dans l'émission c'est les épreuves y en
a moins en moins et de plus en plus de
rapports humains et des rapports humains
assez dégueulasse la plupart du temps
donc cédé malheureusement ça ça pouvait
arriver ouais alors on pose d'autres
questions sur twitter ma ds que les
candidats seront repris pour une
prochaine saison
les candidats bien sûr aux autres qu'ils
ont et qu'ils ont été bien sûr les
victimes collatérales 1 2 de ceux de ce
fait sachez qu'on va et la production va
essayer de les replacer dans d'autres
koh lanta on peut pas leur garantir ils
peuvent pas leur garantir ça mais sachez
qu'ils vont essayer en tout cas de
replacer le plus possible pour qu'il ait
les peaux parce qu'ils ont fait que
quatre jours d'aventuré ils rentrent
chez eux alors mais juste et sachez
aussi que tous les candidats seront
payés intégralement voilà ils seront
payés comme s'il avait fait toute
l'aventuré
donc voilà cessera la production qui va
prendre mais durant ch à tous les coups
et ils seront payés comme s'il avait
fait une aventure complète
voilà tous les candidats de koh lanta ya
une question sylvain douce et qui me dit
y aura-t-il une autre saison elle a
écouté oui y aura une autre saison de
koh lanta koh lanta va reprendre
on va ça va repartir pour une autre
saison jeu
lee forcément et on voit là et c'est
vrai que voilà c'est triste pour pour
cette aventure parce que c'est vrai que
l'on cassé quand même une des émissions
voilà j'aime beaucoup ça va on aime
beaucoup donc il va falloir s'en passer
en septembre moi je pense que c'est bien
un poids ce que de laisser un petit peu
reposé et j'espère que les faits ne
seront pas si grave
les deux candidats ont pris chacun en
avocat la jeune fille a pris maître
temime
et le jeune homme a pris m spécialiste
est exactement alors c'est vrai que
selon plusieurs sources à on apprend
donc il y aurait donc deux personnes
deux autres personnes au moment des
faits dont une qui a contredit la
version de la jeune fille candide et
selon lui ce serait l'autre candidate
aurélie qui malade aurait contacté la
production par talkie-walkie avec l'aide
des dix donc celui qui seraient montrés
du doigt mais juste qui a lâché les noms
dans la presse alors parce que c'est
quand même très dangereux on ne sait pas
une enquête qui est faite et les deux
sont salis quoi qu'il arrive donc c'est
quand même très très dangereux alors
c'est le parisien qui a eu cette info
donc ils sont très bons voilà joly parce
que la production ne souhaitait pas dur
que ça sorte
après je vous le dis forcément les
cherry à des candidats sur koh lanta oui
il ya les réseaux sont sortis très gâté
il a déchanté 50 personnes les 250
personnes il y en a bien qui parle et
qui dit ce qui s'est passé forcément
avec les procès qui seront sur les
réseaux sociaux
les gens ne savent pas exactement ce qui
s'est passé ils prennent parti pour l'un
ou pour l'autre
samedi c'est bien connu enfin ces
discussions ont remplacé les plus
directs pour la storia un procès qu'il
fait déchirer ou on n'en sait vraiment
rien je n'ai pour l'instant parole dans
l'autre parole on va attendre que la
lumière soit faite sur cette affaire
en tout cas pour l'instant tf1 y aura
pas de koh lanta j'oubliais en septembre
la production prend tous les coûts à sa
charge pour tf1 ce sera en pertes
publicitaires 30 millions d'euros de
pertes
ils pensent tf1 peut-être remplacer koh
lanta par ninja warriors une deuxième
édition d'une gerbe rayan mais cette
fois ci en intérieur voilà comme ça se
fait aux états unis je vous le dis avec
des équipes avec deux équipes voilà
c'est peut-être qu'ils feraient pour
remplacer koh lanta et pour réduire les
coûts wizz quelque part je trouve qu'il
faut saluer cette décision parce que
entre la réputation au moment où on
parle de mitu balances ton port etc et
les millions d'euros ils ont choisi la
réputation le respect et je trouve ça
c'est formidable une formidable décision
malgré le coup
les pertes pour les messieurs voilà